[Music]
steve jobs is one of the most
revolutionary men
in history promised nuanced
contributions like computer fonts
and the mouse to his decisive marks with
pixar and of course
apple over the last several years after
steve's death
the wealth of tecmo goals have soared as
they have profited tens of billions
every single year more importantly apple
stock itself has grown 81
in 2020 alone so how much would steve
jobs be worth
[Music]
today
well starting off let's take a look at
steve jobs apple stick over the years
steve jobs started apple with steve
wozniak way back in 1976.
but considering that they didn't have
too much capital to invest into the
company
and the fact that equity had to be
shared with other key voices in the
company as well
steve jobs started with a modest 26
percent stake in apple
after their first funding round in 1977.
by 1985 however this stake would be
watered down to less than half of that
at 11
at this point for a variety of reasons
steve jobs would actually quit
slash b fired from apple he says he quit
but many reports suggest that he was
fired either way though
he left apple in 1985 and steve jobs
being
steve jobs decided that it would be a
great idea to sell his entire stake
as a symbolic move that he didn't need
apple
now steve jobs would return to apple in
and during that time though apple did
have a few notable launches
the company was experiencing a strong
downtrend
and was on the brink of bankruptcy
considering this
you would think that steve jobs made the
right move as he should be able to buy
back in
for a cheaper price than when he left
but
this was during the dotcom bubble so
despite apple being in a workshop
position their stock price was actually
much higher
when steve jobs left apple in september
of 1985
apple stock was only worth 7 cents a
piece he wouldn't become ceo again
until september of 1997 however
he would become significantly
financially invested in the company once
again
during december of 1996. at the time
apple shares were actually worth 21
cents per share
granted these are both literally pennies
in comparison to their stock price
today nonetheless the move out and back
in
heavily diluted steve's position in the
company
when he left he was able to cash out of
21.43 million dollars
which he put towards a series of
investments including a company called
next next inc was a computer and
software company
that steve hoped it would grow large
enough to even compete against apple one
day
though the company never grew that large
it would allow for steve jobs re-entry
into apple as apple would buy next in
december
of 1996. apple bought the company for a
solid 400 million dollars
but steve's stake in the company only
netted him a mere 1.5 million apple
shares
that might sound like a lot and it is
however
in comparison to his original stake this
was nothing
to put that in perspective let's take a
look at how many shares that would be
today since 1997 apple has had a total
of four stock splits which has led each
apple share today to be worth 112 times
less in terms of company ownership
when compared with the shares in 1997.
as a result
steve jobs 1.5 million shares in 1997
would be the same as 168 million shares
today
though that is a lot of shares if steve
jobs didn't sell his shares in a fit of
rage in 1985
he would have had 1.881 billion shares
so that fiasco reduced steve's ownership
11x
bringing down his ownership percentage
to a little less than one percent
but that's not where the story ended
either
see at this point steve jobs was simply
financially invested in the company
and though he held an advisory role he
wasn't ceo
just yet in early 1997 apple would
actually try to appoint a man named
jill emilio as the ceo steve jobs was
not a fan of this move
and he would sell his entire stake again
to protest this appointment
steve jobs would get his way and jill
amelia's appointment would be cancelled
after this steve jobs would be made ceo
again in september of 1997.
as his first and only compensation steve
would receive 5.5 million 2011 shares
which is the same as 1.375 million 1997
shares
with that steve jobs had successfully
watered down his take another 10
but as he would so often say he didn't
join apple again for the money
and this would be clear over the next 14
years steve jobs took a one dollar
salary for the rest of his time at apple
and this was a true one dollar salary as
he received no further stock
compensation
as many ceos today receive from all of
this
we can derive that steve was left with
about 5.5 million shares of apple
at the time of his debt or the same as
154 million shares
today that translates to 2.034 billion
at the time of his death
or 20.43 billion today but wait
there's something wrong with this mat at
the time of steve's debt
his net worth was actually 10.2 billion
meaning that there is an 8.2 billion
discrepancy so where did this money come
from
well ironically though steve jobs was
basically synonymous with
apple and iphone today 80 of his net
worth
wasn't even from apple but actually
disney
after steve jobs left apple in 1985 he
not only invested in next
but also a small animation company
called the graphics group
he bought the graphics group from george
lucas for 10 million
in 1986 and this is actually what would
become pixar
the early days of pixar were quite rough
but this would all change
after the release of toy story in 1995.
that same year pixar would go public at
a share and it looks like the ipo hype
was just as strong back then
as it is today considering that pixar
shares nearly doubled to 39
on just the first trading day steve jobs
owned 30 million shares of pixar
and at 39 a share that comes out to 1.17
billion dollars
making steve jobs a billionaire pixar
would go on to release many more
blockbusters
such as monsters inc toy story 2 finding
nemo and the incredibles
significantly pushing up pixar's
evaluation in 2006
disney would approach pixar with an
acquisition offer
and as we all know this went through
disney bought pixar for 7.4 billion
dollars
out of which 3.7 billion dollars or 138
million shares of disney stock
would make its way to steve jobs so
contrary to popular belief
though apple did make steve jobs rich in
his early days and his late days
it was actually pixar that made him a
billionaire and the vast majority of his
portfolio
and his death was actually disney stock
though disney stock hasn't 10x like
apple stock
they too have grown substantially since
steve's death going severalfold steve's
138 million shares of disney
are worth exactly 25.002 billion dollars
today
adding this to his 20.43 billion dollar
stake in apple
steve jobs would be worth 45.432 billion
dollars today
placing him at about rank 27 on the
billionaires list
and the funniest part is that disney
would actually still make up for the
majority of his net worth
today but that's if he neither received
nor purchased more apple shares
over the last decade steve jobs didn't
receive any apple stock between 1997
and 2011 but that doesn't mean that he
will continue to receive nothing
he didn't take any compensation because
apple was going through a tough time
and he didn't want to burn the company
as much as he could
since 2011 though apple has become a
cash cow
profiting upwards of 60 billion dollars
per year
so they could have easily paid steve
large stock packages
like they do with tim cook but steve
might have declined because of principle
even if he continued to not receive any
stock compensation
he could have bought more apple shares
right after steve's debts in 2012
apple would start paying out dividends
and by 2017
they would end up being the biggest
dividend in the world
i'm not quite sure if steve would have
allowed for a dividend
as he likely would have preferred to
reinvest that money into apple
but maybe he would have come around to
it considering how profitable
apple is if the dividend came to
fruition
even with steve leading the company it's
likely that steve would just use his
dividend payments to buy more apple
shares
thus increasing his stake aside from
this with steve at the top of
apple it's likely that apple would still
be super innovative
apple has managed to be extremely
profitable without steve
but they aren't nearly as innovative as
before
maybe steve jobs continuing to lead the
company would have fixed that
making the company even more valuable
today as a result
taking into account potential stock
compensation dividend reinvestment
and greater growth of apple stock steve
jobs would realistically be worth about
50 billion
today if not a little bit more but
before we end this video there is one
more scenario that we should consider
just for fun what if steve jobs never
sold his apple stake
in reality it's very possible that apple
would have never launched the iphone
if it weren't for steve's time away from
apple and it's likely that steve would
not have gotten involved with pixar
if he hadn't left apple despite this for
the purposes of this example
will say that he invested in pixar
anyways and
that everything at apple progressed
exactly the same way except for steve
selling his 11 person stake
in such a world he would be worth 273
billion dollars
easily topping the billionaire's list
but rage and circumstance had a
different idea
who knows though if steve was alive
maybe
he would have liquidated his disney
stake and invested it all into tesla in
leaving him with over 300 billion
dollars today anyways
what do you guys think about steve jobs
work comment that down below
also drop a like if you guys thought
this video provided a thorough analysis
of steve's potential net worth and of
course consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video
ideas and consider subscribing to see
more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
you